- So you've also re-released
your Christmas album.
Hard Candy Christmas is a classic.
It is hard to have a
classic at Christmas too.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like we all go to the White
Christmas, the Holy Nights,
the Silent that kind of thing.
But that song, one, I just
had a question because is it,
have you always been able to write
with that kind of vulnerability?
- Well actually I did not
write Hard Candy Christmas.
Everybody thinks I did. The
girl that wrote all of that,
the music from The Best Little Whorehouse
in Texas wrote that.
- Cause that's where it's from.
- It's from The Best Little Whorehouse.
But I love that song and
people always tag it to me.
But I get a lot of credit
for a lot of stuff a lot of people do
just because I'm singing it or because...
- Well, no, because
you write a bunch of...
- I do.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's one of the ones I did not write
but everybody thinks I
did and I wish I had.
- I know. But here's the thing though
about that is that's the
storyteller in you too though.
Like it's very, cause
that's what I'm saying.
Like everybody thought that was you
because how you tell that story
is I mean, it just breaks your heart
in the most amazing way.
But it also, I think you being vulnerable
with even with a Coat of Many Colors,
all the songs, literally any song,
like you were a fantastic
writer, not just singer
which is amazing, but it opens up
so many doors for us to be, you know,
as a little kid, I didn't
think any differently.
I thought a woman could speak her mind.
I thought a woman could
say how she was feeling
and that was okay.
I thought that, and I know my mom
and her generation couldn't.
They didn't have that luxury.
So it's just a thank you really.
- Oh, you've made up for it.
(Kelly laughing)
- I did.
- You can say what you want any time.
- Oh, you should hear my next album.
(Kelly laughing)
I made up for it.
- It is snowing in Tahoe.
- Oh, it must be beautiful.
- And it's making me homesick
for how snow's back home at Christmas.
So magical and peaceful.
But Sam, it is only mid-October
and I'm thinking that
is some kind of a sign.
- Maybe some of that magic dust
you're always talking about.
- Well, honestly, I do think
it's more than a coincidence.
I think it's a sign
that I should bring some
of that mountain magic to
everybody this Christmas.
Why don't we do a special from Dollywood?
- Welcome back y'all.
We've got the incomparable
Dolly Parton with us on now.
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- That was another look at her new movie,
Dolly Parton's Mountain Magic Christmas.
It premiers today on NBC.
So by the way, I love that
it's called Mountain Magics.
Why did you call it that?
- Well, because to me
the mountains are magic,
especially the Smokey Mountains
where I was born and raised,
all that beautiful. I mean
it's so beautiful out there.
And of course everybody
should always be proud
of their home wherever you're from.
- Yeah.
- But there's always the magic
in the mountains for
me because that's home.
That's where mom and daddy were.
That's where I grew up with
my brothers and sisters.
That's where all my memories, you know,
started and growing up in
that little country church,
my grandpa was a preacher.
So it's magic to me when I
get a chance to go home now.
And so I always keep that
with me and I think that's important
and that's kind of what the show is about,
trying to capture that magic again.
- Yeah I love that.
Okay, so you also just released
a greatest hits collection
called Diamonds and Rhinestones.
I love the title.
(Dolly laughing)
- Is it true that your song Two Doors Down
was about fried clams?
- It was. But see...
- I need this story.
- I'm like you.
No, I've always had
problem with my weight too.
- Oh, up and down.
- I love to eat. I've been up and down.
I've been every size in the world.
And a long time ago, it
was getting me depressed.
I didn't like it. So I was, you know,
you try everything to lose weight.
And I had got on some
kind of crazy old diet,
like a liquid protein.
You just drink an ounce of something
that's ground up horse hooves
or something. I don't know.
(Kelly laughing)
- I don't know or monkey pee or something.
I don't know what it
was, but it was just...
- This will make you slimmer.
- Yeah, but you supposed to drink it
like three times a day
and it was so ungodly.
You just have to close the back
of your throat off so you don't smell.
You know how it goes but.
- No thanks.
- We used to stay at the
Howard Johnson's Motor Lodge,
the band when we traveled
back in the early days
and they had a restaurant there
and they had these fried clams
that we couldn't wait to stop
to go to Howard Johnson's.
Even if we weren't staying over,
we'd stop to eat the fried clams.
But we were staying over and I was
on that stupid liquid protein
diet and the band was down
in the kitchen and I was
in a hallway in my room
and I could hear them
all laughing and talking.
- That's I'm saying you.
You start to lose time.
- And I would start singing.
I was just saying like two doors down.
♪ Two doors down, they're
laughing and drinking ♪
♪ And having a party ♪
♪ But two doors down, they're
not a aware that I'm around ♪
♪ But here I am just crying
my heart out feeling sorry ♪
- Over fried clams.
♪ Having a party just two doors down ♪
- I was just in there
feeling sorry for myself
cause they was eating
fried clams and I wasn't.
(audience laughing)
- I love that that song is about that.
- And it was two doors down.
I was staying two doors
down from the restaurant.
That's why I... seriously.
- But one of your biggest hits
was I Will Always Love
You. You did write that.
Do you remember the first time
you heard Whitney's version?
- Yes.
- Cause I grew up hearing yours
and then all of a sudden
The Bodyguard happened.
I'm just curious, what was your first,
cause it's your baby?
- Well, there's a little story about that.
When they were doing The Bodyguard movie,
they had chosen another
song for the theme song
and someone came out with that very song
right when they were about
to put the movie out.
And they were, they were drastic to.
I mean they were really
trying to find a great song
and Kevin Costner and
his secretary, they said,
"Do you remember Dolly Parton's song
of I Will Always Love
You? It's a country song
but it's a beautiful song."
And so they called me to see
if they could use it and I said yes.
And I didn't hear anything else about it.
I didn't know if they had it.
I didn't know if they had done it.
And I was driving my car from
downtown where my office was
on 16th Avenue back to my
house over in Brentwood.
And I was just driving along
and I had the radio on
and I just heard this,
"If I should stay," you know...
- Yeah.
- And it's, you know, it's
one of those things like,
it's like a dog hearing a whistle.
You know. I go, what is that?
And all of a sudden...
- That's the first?
- And that's the first time.
They hadn't sent it to me.
They did nothing.
I heard it on the radio.
And so when it went into...
♪ And I ♪
- Yeah.
- And it's like I just freaked out.
I had to pull over to the side
because I honestly
thought I was gonna wreck.
It was the most overwhelming feeling.
And you know how great that was.
- Oh my god
- And it was great.
But that's the story of that.
But when you sang that,
when we did the Academy
of Country Music Awards, when you did that
at the end, I mean, to
tell you that whole crowd,
Whitney, she would've been so proud of you
cause I felt like she was watching you.
You absolutely killed it.
Seriously. It was incredible.
And I was so emotional.
- Me too right now. Like, I'm just,
it hit me that you're like
talking about me singing.
It's fine.
- It was great though.
- No. I will cry.
- It was incredible.
- We're not. They're saying
can you do a little>?
No. I will cry. No.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- How about,
how about if I sing a little bit of it
and you sing harmony with me?
- Okay. Okay.
- Okay. I'll sing a little bit.
♪ And I ♪
♪ Will always love you ♪
♪ I will always love you ♪
♪ You ♪
(audience applauding)
- It's the little things.
It's the little things.
I don't know if y'all heard.
It was like on will but there's this,
your breaks in your voice are so magical.
You're like a magical fairy human.
I don't know.
Anyway, so we need another short break.
Dolly's got two collections
of music out now.
A Holly Dolly Christmas
Ultimate Deluxe Edition
and Diamonds and Rhinestones,
the Greatest Hits Collection.